>> Well, this is my first time at Davos. I've
watched earlier meetings on television, but
it's interesting to be here. The one thing
that really stands out is no matter which
conference I attend, there seems to be very
close to a consensus on many issues. There
are one or two dissenters here and there but
generally whether it's the economy, the environment,
or politics, people seem to agree that right
now we are in a big crisis, and which is self
evident of course, but also at this time it
has really brought home to everyone that everything
is interconnected. There seems to be you can't
talk about one thing without it having an
impact on another area. That has been very
interesting to watch. I also had a chance
to watch some kids yesterday, especially I
think some of the young speakers from Malawi,
really made an impact. It's been great fun.